SANDRA LEUNG LI: Thanks
for joining us
today for this talk.
I am very excited to extend a
warm welcome to chef Joanne
Chang today.
[APPLAUSE]
JOANNE CHANG: Thank you.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: So Joanne is an
honors graduate of Harvard
College with a degree
in applied
mathematics and economics.
She left a career as a
management consultant to enter
the world of professional
cooking.
Before opening Flour, she
honed her skills working
various restaurants, including
the department at Payard in
New York City, and was
previously pastry chef at
Rialto and Mistral
here in Boston.
In 2000, she opened Flour
Bakery and Cafe
in the South End.
Since then, she's opened three
other locations, including
Fort Point Channel, Central
Square, and Back Bay.
In 2007, Joanne opened a Chinese
restaurant in the
South End, called Myers and
Chang, with her husband,
Christopher Myers.
Flour has been featured in
"Gourmet," "Food and Wine,"
"Bon Appetit," and "Boston
Magazine," among other
publications, and has
received numerous
Best of Boston awards.
Also, you may have seen Joanne
prevail versus Bobby Flay in
the sticky bun "Throwdown,"
featured on the Food Network.
And most recently, Joanne was
awarded the 2013 Share Our
Strength Chef of the Year award
for her involvement with
the No Kid Hungry campaign.
So congratulations, Joanne, and
thank you very much for
joining us today.
JOANNE CHANG: Thank
you for having me.
[APPLAUSE]
SANDRA LEUNG LI: You just
released your new cookbook
yesterday, actually, right?
JOANNE CHANG: Mm hmm.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: So you must be
ramping up for a very busy
month of book touring.
JOANNE CHANG: Yes.
When the first book came out,
I actually did come here to
Google and you guys welcomed me
just as warmly last time,
so thank you.
When the first book came out, I
said to my publisher, so is
there a book tour?
And they said, no, we don't
really do that anymore.
I think with bloggers and Food
Network and all of that, they
really were putting all of their
energies and monies in
people who they knew would
get a big audience.
So they didn't book me anything,
which is fine.
And then I did a lot of stuff
locally, and then I went to
New York once.
This time around, I don't
know what has changed.
I've never really asked
them what happened.
I think the success of the
first book helped.
I'm not really sure, actually.
So this time, the book came out
yesterday, and I'm going
to the West Coast, Toronto, the
Midwest, and Texas, all in
the next couple of months, day
trips here and there, and then
three and four-day trips and
taking advantage of being out
on the West Coast.
I'm pretty excited.
I've never really travelled for
the book, so I'm curious
to see what it will be like.
When I come to Boston, most
people know Flour, and it's
easy for me to talk about it,
and people have questions that
are all relevant to what
I do every day.
So I'm very curious to see what
happens when I go to a
place where nobody's ever
heard of Flour or me.
And I'm hoping it's not three
people and me, but we'll see.
We'll see.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: I think
it'll be more.
JOANNE CHANG: I hope so.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: What's your
favorite city that
you'll be going to?
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, that's
a good question.
Well, we're going to San
Francisco, which I'm really
excited about.
I don't get there very often,
so I am excited to go there.
And then I'm going to Dallas,
which is where my parents are,
so I'm excited to be
able to do that.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Cool.
So I imagine you have a lot of
fans that come out to see you.
Clearly, we have quite
a few here at Google.
What is the oddest encounter you
have had from a fan at one
of these events?
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, boy.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: There
might be a weird
encounter after this.
I don't know.
JOANNE CHANG: Exactly.
If I'm describing you
right now, I still
think you're wonderful.
So last night, I was actually
Wellesley books.
And when I came home, my husband
said, so how was it?
And I said, this was the first
book signing that I've done
where there wasn't some crazy
person who came up to me.
Every now and then, there will
be somebody who is extremely
enthusiastic about either me
or sticky buns or pastry.
It could be anything.
And I don't think it's
personal to me.
I think they just latched onto
whatever it is about me or the
book that has resonated
with them.
And usually, at book signings
that are kind of out in the
world, versus here, where I feel
like there's probably,
hopefully, nobody that crazy,
there's always somebody who
will stay at the very end and
stay at the table and want to
talk for about three hours.
Of course, I love talking to
people who love Flour, I love
talking about baking, and I
could talk for three hours
about the book.
So it's not that talkative
people are weird.
It's just sometimes there are
fans who get a little bit too
intimate and want to
know details and--
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Take
note, guys.
JOANNE CHANG: I'm just not ever
sure how to graciously
back away from that.
I had one woman who basically
followed me from book signing
to book signing the
first time around.
And every time, at the very
end, she waited until
everybody left, and she spent a
lot of time stroking my arm
and telling me how much
she loved me.
She was very, very sweet, and
it was one of those things
where I just felt bad, because
I didn't know how to--
It would be better if she were
really rude, because then I
could say, I don't want
to deal with you.
But she was so nice,
so what do you do?
You're too nice?
I didn't know what to say.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Try
that next time.
So why did you decide to come
out with your second cookbook?
JOANNE CHANG: After writing the
first one, I definitely
knew I wanted to
write a second.
I really loved the whole
book-writing process.
But I thought that the second
cookbook would be "Myers and
Chang," which is the Asian
restaurant I own with my
husband in the South End.
And in fact, I had already
started testing recipes and
was ready to write a proposal
to send off to Chronicle.
And when the first book came
out, immediately readers were
sending me emails or tweets and
Facebook posts or whatever
saying, I really
love the book.
I'm making such and such.
What happened to this recipe?
What happened to that recipe?
I thought the first book was
relatively complete, until I
started getting all of these
inquiries, and people were
asking about the egg sandwich or
the brown sugar oat muffin
or the lemon ginger mousse or
other things that we do at the
bakery that just, for whatever
reason, had slipped my mind.
So I started to get a number of
these inquiries, and about
the same time, my publisher,
Chronicle, reached out and
said, we would like to do
a second book with you.
I know you want to do "Myers
and Chang," but we actually
think there's an opportunity
with the second part of Flour,
basically the savory end.
We originally had a savory
chapter in the first Flour
book, but it got cut because
the book was too big.
And so we took out that
whole chapter.
So I was already one up on
chapters for this potential
second book, and then I had
this list of emails with
literally probably 20 inquiries
of different things
that people wanted from Flour.
So it became a natural next
book, even though it wasn't
what immediately came to my
mind, to do "Flour, Too."
SANDRA LEUNG LI: And it sounds
like there could be a third
book coming out too.
JOANNE CHANG: Well, again, I
think the third book should be
"Myers and Chang,"
but my publisher
has a different idea.
So I am signing a deal with them
some time this week to do
a low-sugar baking book,
which is interesting.
I know that everyone's
kind of like, wow,
where'd that come from?
I don't know where
it came from.
Again, they reached out to me.
This is how it works.
At Chronicle Books, the
food/cookbook publisher, she
is married to a doctor who is
colleagues with the guy who
wrote the sugar is toxic
article that was in the
"Times" about six months ago.
I don't know if you guys saw
it, but it was a really
interesting article.
And for me, as somebody who
lives in plying sugar to
others, it was a little bit
nerve-wracking to read that
and think, oh, gosh,
what's going to
happen now to my business?
It was the same fear I had when
we first opened Flour and
Atkins diet was a big thing
and no gluten and all that
sort of stuff.
Anyway, the editor, she called
me and said, you know, we are
really interested in thinking
about what the future of
baking might be.
Because they spend a lot of
time looking forward to
trends, and so in order for
them to come out with a
gluten-free baking book today or
a Paleo baking book today,
they have to know that it's
something that's going to be
popular like three or
four years ago.
She's anticipating that
low-sugar will be something
that will be interesting in two
or three years, and so she
asked me if I would be
interested in considering it.
And honestly, for me, I read
that article, the sugar is
toxic, and I do know for myself
I eat a lot of sugar
every day, and I know how
it makes me feel.
I get that sugar rush,
I get really
energized, and then I crash.
And I've just gotten
used to it.
It's just kind of what I do.
But if I were trying to eat more
healthily, or if I were
raising a family, and if I was
just trying to be more
thoughtful about how I eat,
then I would want
to reduce my sugar.
And so I tested a bunch of
recipes, because I didn't want
to say, yes, I'll do this book,
without knowing if it
was even possible.
And I tested two really popular
recipes from the first
baking book, the banana bread
and the oatmeal raisin cookie.
And I was able to successfully
make both of them with either
a third or half the amount
of sugar that's
listed in the book.
In fact, I made them for the
bakers at the Flour South End
location, and most of them
preferred the new low-sugar
version to the current
version.
So to me, that was a really good
sign that, one, it can be
done and then, two, that
it would be fun.
I really enjoyed the
whole process.
Baking, it's fun and creative
when you get to
do things like this.
When you're doing things every
day, it starts to get a little
bit monotonous, and then you
get thrown a challenge like
this, and you're reminded of
why you got into it in the
first place.
So that's the next book.
I did ask my publisher if I was
allowed to talk about it,
because at first we weren't
going to talk about it.
And he said, yes, as long
as we don't tell
the publishing world.
So I don't know if there's
anybody in here--
SANDRA LEUNG LI: It will
be on YouTube.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, I think they
don't want it in "Publishers
Weekly." That's what
I'm assuming.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: All right.
Well, we'll make sure it'll
stay in this room.
JOANNE CHANG: In the bubble.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: So what is
your favorite recipe from
"Flour, Too"?
JOANNE CHANG: That's
a good question.
Gosh, favorite recipe.
That's so hard.
My favorite thing to eat from
the "Flour, Too" book would be
the Kouign Amann, which is the
butter Breton cake, which is
in the "Party Time" section
of the book.
I first had butter Breton
cake 15 or 20 years ago
when I was in Paris.
It was before we opened Flour,
and I remember biting into it.
It is basically a croissant that
is made with extra butter
and extra sugar so that it
becomes really, really crispy
and caramelized on the edge,
and it's still flaky.
You know what?
You know this whole thing
with the cronut?
I'm sure you guys all
know about it.
It's sort of like that.
It's got the same thing that the
cronut has going for it.
It's got the crunchy on
the outside and the
flaky on the inside.
So when I first had it 15,
20 years ago, I remember
thinking, if I ever open my own
place, we're going to make
Kouign Amann.
We opened Flour, and I
developed a recipe.
But it was really difficult to
make on a day-to-day basis.
And so we offered only at the
holidays for 11 years.
Then I started writing this
book, and I wanted to put the
recipe in the book.
And I told my executive pastry
chef, if it's in the book,
we're going to have to
offer it every day.
So about a year ago, we figured
out the production,
and now we're offering
it every day.
So I would say that's probably
one of my favorites.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: That
sounds delicious.
And I am a big fan
of the cronut.
JOANNE CHANG: I haven't
had it yet.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: I want to go
back in time a bit and have
you think back to the first
time you ever baked.
When was that?
And what did you bake?
JOANNE CHANG: The first time I
ever baked, I was probably 10.
Let me think about this.
No, actually, the first time,
I think I was about 7.
I remember this now.
And it wasn't even baking.
But for some reason, I thought,
I'm going to make
something with my friend.
I can't remember his
name, like Tim.
We were little seven-year-olds,
right?
My parents both worked.
And I remember, because my mom
got really mad afterwards, I
crossed the freeway so that I
could get to the 7-Eleven to
buy ingredients, and then we
crossed the freeway back.
And we made--
This isn't really baking, but I
assume this is kind of what
you're going for--
little fruit kebabs.
We bought whatever fruit you can
buy over at 7-Eleven, and
we cut it all up, and we
put it on toothpicks.
We put it in little baggies,
and then we forgot about it
for a day and brought it the
next day to our teachers, at
which point the bananas were all
mushy and the apples were
all yellowed.
But we were so proud.
And I do remember giving it to
my teacher and just being
really excited that I had made
something and given it to her
because I loved her.
So it wasn't really baking,
but that was like my first
time in the kitchen.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: And was
that the beginning of
what got you hooked?
Or when was the first moment?
JOANNE CHANG: I've always
loved to be in the--
After that, I definitely spent
time in the kitchen.
My mom was a working mom.
And so I would come home from
school, and she would often
need help, basically, just
putting together dinner.
I got to be pretty adept in
helping her just prep stuff,
so by the time she got
home, she could
just do a quick stir-fry.
Or I would put stuff in the oven
and get the rice ready,
or whatever.
So I'd always very comfortable
in the kitchen.
I think that the first
time that I ever
thought about it truly--
I thought about it
professionally very, very late.
It wasn't until after college.
But when I was in college,
I did make chocolate chip
cookies in the dormitory
kitchen, and I sold them to
the dormitory Grill.
And I sold them to the guys who
ran the Grill for $0.25
each, and they sold
them three for $1.
I did it for two years, junior
and senior year.
And I remember I guess every
semester they would write me a
check for the proceeds, and
it was like $60 or $70.
And I would use the money to go
buy running shoes, because
I was a runner.
So that was kind of my first
foray into making food that
then people paid you for.
But I certainly didn't think
at that point, oh, great.
Now I'm going to go
and open a bakery.
At that point, it was a
way to kill some time.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: So you
mentioned running shoes.
And I did read how you ran every
single Boston Marathon
from '91 to 2006.
Was that your strategy, run a
marathon, eat, [INAUDIBLE].
JOANNE CHANG: No.
I don't run as much anymore,
which is unfortunate, because
I really do miss it.
But I definitely think that when
you're working all day in
a kitchen and you're surrounded
by food and you're
eating food all day long,
there's something that's just
very relaxing.
And for me, it's good for
my mind to go out and
go for a long run.
And so for years it
was my thing.
I calmed myself down, and it
was my little zen thing.
I'm not a speed runner.
It took me like five or
six hours each time,
just plodding along.
But it's just something that
definitely helps balance the
amount of eating that
you do all day long.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: You're a
Harvard graduate and former
management consultant turned
chef restaurant owner.
I come from your stereotypical
Asian household, so the first
thing that I would like to know
is, what did your parents
think when you quit your
management consultant job to
become a pastry chef?
JOANNE CHANG: That's
a great question.
When it happened, it wasn't
quite as black
and white as that.
I didn't say, I'm quitting and
dropping everything and going
to do this.
I was at the end of my second
year as a management
consultant.
And at that time, that's when
people either went on to
business school, or some people
were staying within the
company, and they were going to
just kind of keep going up
and up within in company.
And I didn't want
either of those.
I didn't want to stay, and I
definitely didn't want to go
to business school So I was kind
of stuck, and I didn't
know what to do next.
And I'd always loved to cook and
to bake, and so I thought,
you know what?
I'll take a year off, and I'll
try cooking professionally and
see if I can support myself
for at least a year.
And then I'll figure out
what I want to do.
So that's kind of how I
sold it to my parents.
I didn't have this plan
that it was going
to be a career change.
It was just taking care
a year off to do
something that I enjoyed.
I think that for them was a
little bit easier to swallow
than if I had said, I'm chucking
the whole thing, and
I'm going to go become a chef.
They were cautiously
supportive.
I think they were definitely
very nervous.
I was 24.
And if you're 24, you think
you know everything.
But if you're 50, like my
parents were, you think that
the 24-year-old knows nothing.
And so they were just really,
really nervous.
How are you going to
support yourself?
You're leaving this
really stable job.
It's got a lot of benefits.
You're not going to have
health insurance.
What are you going to do?
So I think they were more
concerned about logistically
how was I going to
survive for year.
And then when it became clear
that it was more than just a
passing fancy, at that
point I think they
saw how happy I was.
And I was able to make it
work financially, so
they were more accepting.
Then as I got pastry chef jobs,
it seemed even a little
bit more legitimate
in their eyes.
And then when we opened the
bakery, then it was a real
thing, and so they
were OK with it.
And now they love it.
Now they come all the
time, and they
go to all the bakeries.
In fact, they will always do
Kayak or whatever to find out
what hotel they should
stay in.
And they'll send me an email and
say, OK, this hotel, how
far is it away from
the bakeries?
And I'm always like, mom, what
about how far is it from me,
the one you're coming
to visit?
They will come for a week, and
I might see them three times,
but all the staff will see
them dozens of times.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Do you
have any siblings?
JOANNE CHANG: I do.
I have a younger brother, who
went to MIT and studied--
mechanical engineering?
Some sort of engineering.
Chemical?
No--
engineering of some sort.
He's brilliant, and he worked
for years for Harrah's out in
Las Vegas doing some of their
something, something
computer-related.
And then he just recently took a
job with Darden Corporation,
which owns Olive Garden, Red
Lobster, Capital Grille.
So he's technically in the food
business now, but he's
still on the computer end.
He's assistant to the
CFO, or something.
I don't really know.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Sounds
really smart.
JOANNE CHANG: He's very smart.
And he just--
SANDRA LEUNG LI: I was
going to say--
JOANNE CHANG: --got
his first patent.
I was very proud.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: --if you have
siblings, maybe you could
deflect some of the attention in
those early stages when you
were trying to switch over, if
your younger brother was doing
something else.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, no.
Because at that point, he was
here at MIT getting his
mechanical engineering
degree, I think.
They were very proud of him,
as they should have been.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: You opened
Flour back in 2000.
What were your greatest
challenges
in those early days?
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, man.
Something that I think I forget
about-- and I don't
know if it's just one of those
survival things that do-- is
the entire first year of opening
the bakery, I wanted
to close it.
In fact, I have a diary that I
kept at the time, and there's
an entry about the 10th month
where I said, can't wait to
sell this place.
Mom says I should keep
it at least a year.
At that point, I'd told my mom
this isn't really working out.
I don't really think this
was a good idea.
And my mom was just like, just
keep it for a year, just to
save face, to say that you at
least did it for a year.
And then you can sell it.
And the biggest challenges, for
me, were that I have this
vision of what I wanted
the bakery to be.
I had recipes.
I had, in my head, all these
wonderful scenarios of
customers coming in and getting
great, friendly service.
And the milk pitcher was
full, so you could put
milk in your coffee.
Then you get your beautifully
packaged pastry, and go home
and enjoy it.
You think about that when you're
planning a bakery.
Then the reality is the customer
comes in, and the
staff member is busy talking to
their co-staff member, and
the milk picture isn't full, and
they pack all the pastries
smushed in a bag.
And you get the email from the
customer saying, I ordered all
these pastries, I spent this
much money, and here's the
picture of how my pastries
looked when I got home.
I really struggled with taking
the vision that I had and then
trying to disseminate that
amongst the staff and trying
to impart upon them the goal
that I was trying to do with
Flour and the missions that
we were trying to do.
That was the hardest part for
that whole first year is that
I was only one person.
And I had a hard time and a
really steep learning curve on
learning how to delegate,
learning how to manage.
I'd been a manager at the
various pastry chef jobs I'd
had, but that was
very different.
And all of a sudden, at the
time, it was 12 employees, all
of whom were great people--
I still keep in touch with many
of them-- but just had a
different idea of what
Flour should be on
a day-to-day basis.
And so that constant struggle
of walking in and seeing the
place be so different from what
I had intended and what I
had worked so hard to create,
and then going home and coming
back and having the same
thing happen every day.
I kept trying to
right the ship.
And I would go away for 15
minutes, and the ship would go
off that way.
Then I'd come back and right it,
and it would go off again.
And on top of that, in the whole
first year, I didn't
take a day off until
about 10 months in.
And then I was doing
all of the baking.
So that was coming in at 3:00
in the morning and doing the
bake off and then staying
there all day long.
Also, again because I was a
small business, I was doing
all of the accounting, all of
the payroll, all of that back
office stuff.
So that was happening late at
night, and then I'd go to bed
and wake up again and
do the whole thing
over starting at 3:00.
So a couple months in, or
however long, you just start
to get really exhausted.
And when the milk pitcher isn't
filled, it just seems
like, OK, this isn't worth it.
I should sell the place.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: When did it
start to turn and pick up?
JOANNE CHANG: Definitely between
that 10th month and
that first year where I
had vowed to sell it.
The key where it started to turn
was I finally had staff
that I trusted.
Not that previously
I didn't trust.
They were all very
trustworthy.
But I finally had staff that
could do what I did in the way
that I wanted them.
For me, the big thing
was opening.
It is being the first person to
turn on the ovens, to take
all the pastries that are ready
to go, to put them in
the ovens, mix the batters and
get everything ready so that
by 7:00 AM you can have the
pastry display ready for
guests when they come in.
Around the 10th month,
I trained somebody
who's still with me.
She's my executive
pastry chef.
She's been made partner.
And Nicole learned
how to open, and
that gave me a breather.
It gave me one day that I could
actually sleep in till
probably 5:00 in the morning.
It was just something that
gave me a little bit of
perspective.
It's just so hard when you're
just doing it day in, day, in,
day in, day out.
And so having that person who
could share a little bit of
the responsibility was key.
And then from that came a front
of the house manager.
When we opened, we had a front
of the house manager, but he
didn't end up working out.
So then we didn't have
one for a long time.
And by about in the end of the
first year, we hired somebody
who is really terrific, so then
she could do all of the
hiring and training of
the counter staff.
The key was just getting a team
around me that understood
what we were trying to do.
And once I felt that they
understood, then the mistakes
became, not irrelevant, but they
didn't bother me as much.
It's like, OK, we all make
mistakes, right?
So they would make a mistake,
and it's like, that's OK,
because I knew they wanted
to do the right thing.
It was in the beginning when
nobody knew what I was trying
to do that when mistakes were
made they didn't understand,
which was this constant
struggle.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: I think a lot
of folks in this room have
similar entrepreneurial spirit
and may strive to launch their
own business some day.
What advice would you give
to budding entrepreneurs?
JOANNE CHANG: For me, definitely
it's about creating
and developing a team of people
that surround you and
who believe in what you do.
I remember in that first year
just thinking, man, did I do
this wrong.
I should have gotten a little
kiosk that was just manned by
me with a little commissary
kitchen, where I would be the
only one baking and then the
only one selling and then the
only one washing dishes.
Because I was feeling like
I'm the only one
who can do this right.
So for people who want to start
their own businesses,
unless you're one-man
show, you need to
rely on other people.
And so the biggest advice that I
tell anybody, usually people
come up to me and they say,
I want to open a bakery.
What do I do?
And it is creating those
relationships around you and
developing people around you
who understand what you're
trying to do and who believe in
it and who can help you get
to where you're trying to go,
because you really can't do
anything by yourself.
When I was planning for the
bakery, I was in New York City
working at Payard, and at the
end of my stint at Payard, I
spent about three or four weeks
with Amy Scherber of
Amy's Breads.
She was very generous and said,
yep, you can come and
hang out with us for a month
and learn what you want to
learn about brand.
And I asked her, in exchange
for my working for a month,
can I pick your brain
for an hour or so?
So at the end of my month
there, I asked
her the same question.
I'm like, I want to go
open my business.
What do I need to know?
And she said, human resources.
You need to find people.
So I had ended my internship.
My mom came to New York
to pick me up.
I had two days in New
York with my mom.
And the very next day, after my
goodbye interview with Amy,
she called me the next morning
and said, is there any way you
can do the whatever, whatever
shift, because so-and-so just
walked out.
And I couldn't, because my mom
was there with me, and we were
getting ready to leave.
But it just really hammered home
that, man, without people
you can't do that much.
You can have a great idea.
You can personally
be a great baker.
You can be a great salesman.
But unless you're willing to do
every single thing on your
own, you're not going
to succeed.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Yeah.
Great advice.
So here at Google, we are always
trying to innovate and
stay ahead of the curve.
As a chef, how do
you innovate?
JOANNE CHANG: That's
a great question.
Because we have challenges in
that area, in that, for us,
people who come to
the bakery--
I think at a certain point you
have to just decide what is
your audience and what are you
trying to do and to be true to
what you want to do.
So we try to innovate.
We try to add new sandwiches.
We try to change things up.
We are physically limited by
what we can produce to a set
number, a rough number of
things, so we can't just
constantly add things.
If we add something, we have
to take something away.
And what we have found over
the years, especially as
Flour's gotten bigger and
people associate us with
certain things, it's really
difficult for us to innovate
without pissing off
a lot of people.
We tried last summer to change
the turkey sandwich.
I don't know if any of you
guys are turkey sandwich
aficionados, but my gosh, you
would've thought I stole
people's first child.
I got so many emails like,
what did you do?
Why did you do this?
What is wrong?
For every person who was upset,
we probably get 10
"what's wrong with you?" to
1 "we really like the new
sandwich." So we stuck it out
for, I think, six or eight
months, and then I was
continuing to get the emails.
And finally, we just said, OK,
let's just switch back.
So it's hard for us to try to
come up with new products.
But in terms of innovating in
terms of how we run our
business, we are constantly
trying to think of ways.
You guys are an inspiration,
what you guys do within the
company to try to create good
working environments and to
foster creativity.
I read all the articles about
Google, and I think, oh, what
can we do from that to help
inspire the staff
who work for me?
We have a very different
group of employees.
A lot of them, it's their
part-time job
because they're in school.
Or they've taken a year off
from something, and then
they're moving on.
So there's definitely a
different environment, but
there's still the same capacity
to inspire people to
take that moment that they're
working for us at Flour and be
the best Flour person
they can.
So for us, we try to innovate in
terms of how do we energize
them and get them excited and
make them understand that even
though this is only your
part-time job and you're only
here for three months, it's
still really important for us
that you view this as if this
is your life goal, to be the
best counter person
or baker you can.
We brainstorm a lot, and we just
think about what we can
do, what we can offer to the
staff to give them that
environment.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Very cool.
How did you decide on the
name Flour Bakery?
JOANNE CHANG: Flour came
from my husband.
I was in New York,
and I called him.
We weren't dating at the time.
He was just a friend.
And I called him, and I
said, I'm thinking of
coming back to Boston.
I want to open my own bakery.
Do you have any ideas?
And he came up with a list of
names, none of which I can
really remember.
Flour was one of them, and
I remember thinking, that
doesn't work.
There's a list of them, and I
thought, that doesn't work,
that doesn't work, that
doesn't work.
None of them worked,
basically.
And then I think a week or so
later, I was just looking at
the list again, and I
was playing around
with the word Flour.
It just seemed weird.
Why would you name
a bakery Flour?
It just sounded so plain
and uninspired.
And then it kind
of grew on me.
And then I thought, it's like
anybody's first name.
If you have an unusual first
name, it sounds weird to
people until they
get to know you.
And after the fifth time, it
just becomes your name.
So for me, Flour was the same.
Flour sounded weird, and then
after thinking about it, I
thought, OK, this could work.
And now it just seems like a
no-brainer, and I'm very
grateful for him for
coming up with it.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: It sounds like
he inceptioned you or
hypnotized you in some way.
JOANNE CHANG: That might
have happened.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: You mentioned
in the early days you were
waking up at 3:00 AM.
What is a typical day
like for you today?
JOANNE CHANG: Totally
different.
If it weren't for the book,
typically I try to go to two
Flour locations a day,
morning at one,
afternoon at the other.
And then three or four times
a week, I try to go to the
restaurant in the evening.
What I'm doing now is a little
bit of what I was talking
about earlier.
The innovation with the staff,
which for me really is getting
to know the staff, and so I come
in and I taste products
and I talk to everybody.
And I just try to
get a sense of--
They're in the middle
of their day.
They're either serving coffee,
or they're baking off cookies,
or they're making soup
or something.
So I try not to interrupt their
day, but I do try to
find good times within the
morning that I'm there to
stand next to certain staff
people and just talk to them
and find out what they're doing
and how's this working
and, hey, we just got this
new piece of equipment.
What do you think?
Or in the front of the house,
wow, we just got
this new iced tea.
How's it selling?
So I spend a fair amount of time
just trying to actually
just connect with the staff.
Because we have so many people,
and I feel like if I
don't stay connected with them
not that I'll forget what
Flour's all about but I will
forget that connection of the
staff to the customer.
So it's really important for
me to stay close to them.
And then I spend a lot of time
in the office doing either
managerial stuff.
We have a lot of manager
meetings.
Each location has its own
manager meeting that I attend.
And then I have a manager
meeting with my director of
operations, and with my
executive pastry chef, and
with my human resource
director.
So there's a lot of meetings.
And then from the meetings, I
spend a lot of time in front
of the computer summarizing
the meetings and doing
followups to the meetings.
So it's just a lot
of office work.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Sounds
a lot like Google.
You could be here.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, really?
SANDRA LEUNG LI: From the sound
of it, it seems like you
probably don't get a chance
to cook at home very much.
JOANNE CHANG: I don't.
I miss that a lot.
In fact--
Where was I?
Oh, I was just driving down, I
don't know the name of the
street, but in downtown where
there's a grocery store where
used to go all the time.
And I was just driving down
there last week, and I
thought, man, I haven't been to
that grocery store in-- and
then I start counting, and I
said-- six years since we
opened Myers and Chang.
There's really no reason
for me to cook.
I enjoy it, but it's so easy
just to go to the restaurant
to get take out and
bring it home.
So we do a lot of that.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: And so you must
be an expert, obviously,
on all the dishes at
Myers and Chang--
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, yeah.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: --with
the take out.
What do you usually take out?
JOANNE CHANG: Let's see.
We get the salmon.
It's a pan-roasted,
soy-glazed salmon.
It's very, very simple.
It's definitely not the dish
that I recommend when I'm
trying to show off about what
Myers and Chang is all about,
but it's my favorite dish.
It's really simple
and delicious.
We get the lamb belly.
It's a lamb belly stir-fry with
slippery glass noodles
and leeks and sesame seeds.
The spicy salmon and apple
tartare with sesame crisps is
one of my favorites.
We always get a vegetable.
Yeah.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Sounds good.
I want to leave a little time
for audience questions, but
just a few last fun questions
before we finish up.
What would be your last meal?
JOANNE CHANG: My last
meal, I would have--
I love--
Wow.
OK.
I would do lots of things.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: That's
cheating.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, really?
Is that really cheating?
It's your last meal--
SANDRA LEUNG LI: OK.
Go for it.
JOANNE CHANG: --so you
could eat everything.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Go
big or go home.
JOANNE CHANG: Yeah, I can't
think of a composed last meal.
I would probably go to Oishii
and have omakase.
And then I would save a little
room, and I would go to Picco
and have a pizza.
And then I would go to the
7-Eleven and buy Haagen-Dazs
coffee ice cream and eat
the whole thing.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: That
is a healthy meal.
What is on your music
playlist?
JOANNE CHANG: This is sad.
I don't listen to music.
In fact, last night driving out
to Wellesley, I thought, I
should turn on the radio just
to see, what are people
listening to these days?
I don't even know what
playlist means.
I don't listen at all.
I used to listen to a hip hop
station, pop station, KISS
108, because I used to
run to headphones.
And then my headphones got
stolen three years ago, and I
just stopped listening.
When I'm listening, if I were to
ever listen, I actually, at
this point now, I feel like I've
gotten old, but I really
do like classical music.
Because my dad loves classical,
so there's a lot of
fond memories when I listen
to certain things.
I have a couple CDs that
I'll stick in the
thing, whatever it is.
But I'm not really
a music person.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: It sounds
like we need to work on
getting you headphones.
What do you do for fun?
JOANNE CHANG: I love going
out to eat with
Christopher and friends.
That's definitely something that
I enjoy a lot and look
forward to when we can
schedule it in.
I still run and exercise
every day, which
might sound not fun.
But for me, it's very fun.
I love to read.
I don't have enough time
to just sit and relax.
So my ideal is on Sunday
mornings to wake up and have
breakfast with Christopher and
then just read the paper
slowly over the course
of the day.
Yeah.
Those are the three things
that I like to do.
I like to shop, but I don't
spend a lot of time shopping.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Oh.
And the last question, I noticed
the Flour motto to
"Make Life Sweeter.
Eat Dessert First." So do you
really eat dessert first?
JOANNE CHANG: Well, I'm
kind of eating a
dessert all day long.
So by the time I get to dinner,
I actually feel like I
need to eat some food.
I'm very conscious of the fact
that I don't eat real food
usually until dinner time.
But on days that I'm not at
the bakery, I think it's
important to eat dessert
first, because you
might not have room.
I've had plenty of dinners where
I've run out of room by
the end of the dinner.
So if I can, I try
to sneak it in.
It's a little odd.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Love
that strategy.
JOANNE CHANG: Sometimes
the servers are
like, are you sure?
But we've seen customers at
Myers and Chang do that.
They'll order the nasi goreng
and the arctic char roll and
coconut cream pie.
And I'm always like,
are you sure?
And they're like, yeah, we want
to eat dessert as well.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Cool.
Now I want to open it up
to audience question.
So if anybody has any questions,
you guys can line
up here so we can get
you on the mic.
Don't be shy.
AUDIENCE: I'll come up.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Yeah.
AUDIENCE: Do I really
have to go?
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Yes, you do.
AUDIENCE: Oh.
All right.
Just curious, so now you're in
four locations around Boston.
How connected are you to the
communities and the other
restaurant owners and
bakery owners?
Do you guys help each other
out and stay in touch?
JOANNE CHANG: The restaurant and
bakery community in Boston
and Cambridge is extremely
tight-knit.
Everybody knows everybody.
Everybody sees everybody at
events and goes to everybody's
restaurants.
So yes, we're very connected.
I feel very connected.
In fact, we're looking for
a sous-chef position
at Myers and Chang.
And I just this morning sent an
email out to all of my chef
friends just saying, if you know
of anybody, or if there's
anybody on your team that is
ready to move on and you don't
need them, send them our way.
So we all feel very connected.
I will reach out to Maura at
Sofra on a periodic basis, or
vice versa, if she needs
something or if I need
something, her advice.
The woman who runs Tatte Bakery,
her pastry chef used
to work for me as my pastry
chef, and so Kristin and I
stay in touch.
And then, all the chefs, they
just all know each other.
We work really well together.
AUDIENCE: I was just wondering,
I like to test
around the kitchen as well
quite a bit, but I never
actually remember the recipes.
So I didn't know, when you go
into testing a new recipe, do
you take down the
measurements?
Or what's your process
for doing that so you
can remember it again?
JOANNE CHANG: I definitely
write it down first.
One of the things I tell people
what I'm doing a demo,
for example, is you know when
you're watching on Food TV,
and they have all the little
cups with everything all
measured out, and they
go, boom, boom,
boom and it's done?
That's actually how I bake.
If I'm testing a recipe-- like
right now I'm in the middle of
this low-sugar thing--
I write down a recipe that in
my head I think will work.
And then I go and I measure
everything out, and then I
have my piece of paper with
a pen next to me.
And as I'm baking, if I
see an adjustment--
I'll add a cup of milk and
realize ooh, it needs more
liquid-- then I'll add it and
I'll measure another quarter,
and then I'll change
the recipe.
For me, it's not like cooking.
If I'm just cooking at home,
I wouldn't think
so much about it.
But because I need to replicate
it, I have to be
really careful about taking
really detailed notes.
It can be a little bit less fun,
because you're trying to
just make something delicious,
and then, aw, shoot, I got to
remember to write this down.
But I've gotten used to it over
testing these two books
these past couple years.
So it's definitely the best
way in order to be able to
replicate it going forward.
AUDIENCE: You have a few
successful businesses that
you've started.
You've written a couple
of books.
At this point, you said you
make it into some of your
businesses some of the time,
depending on what you can fit
in the schedule.
So they're obviously sustaining
themselves in ways
that was not possible
at the beginning.
How self-sustaining are
your businesses?
And what's next for you, given
that you've been able to free
up some of the time
in your schedule?
JOANNE CHANG: Sure.
The businesses, at this point,
if I were to just drop off the
face of the Earth, there's a
couple things that I do that
I'm still the only
one who does.
But it wouldn't be hard
to teach somebody.
So for example payroll, which
happens every other week, I
have an HR person.
She runs payroll.
She talks to all the managers to
make sure everybody's time
clocks are correct.
But I physically enter it into
our accounting system, because
I want to see how much we're
paying everybody.
That's easy enough.
If I were to move to Tahiti, I
could just teach her how to do
that part, and she
could do it.
Honestly, I think that's
the only thing
that I do that I have--
And I field a lot
of the email.
We get a lot of emails, either
complaints or requests for
information or charity
requests.
And I tend to answer most of
them, especially the complaint
ones, just because they are
important to me, and I want to
stay on top of them all.
But that, again, I could also
easily give that to my
director of operations,
who would gladly do
all of that for me.
I think what would be missing,
and it's one of the reasons
why I don't want to not be at
the bakeries as much as I can,
is the connection that I have
with the staff, trying to make
them understand the
story of Flour.
And we're at this point where
some people call us a chain.
And I don't want it ever
to feel like that.
We were talking earlier
about how Google's
gotten really big.
And I'm sure that whoever the
big people are wish it were
still small.
And so trying to maintain that
small company atmosphere, even
though it's gotten bigger, is
something that I think I'm
uniquely positioned to
do, simply because I
don't have a job title.
My executive pastry chef, she's
in charge of pastry, so
she spends all her time actually
working on pastries.
And the HR person,
she does HR.
But for me, I'm just owner.
So what do I do?
I try to make sure that the
place that they are working at
is what I intended it to be.
Because I think it's very easy,
without guidance, for it
to, like I was saying earlier,
just veer off, and not
necessarily in a bad way, but
just in a way that's not what
I intended.
And so it's not that my way is
the right way, but I think
there's something to be said
for running a business that
has a clear vision.
And if there's not one person or
one group of people that's
kind of setting the vision on a
daily basis and having that
be their focus, I think it's
easy for companies
to lose their way.
I don't know if that really
answers your question.
It's not like a specific job
thing that I do conscious--
I do it consciously, but there's
not a list of things I
do to do that.
It's just kind of how I
try to stay connected
to the various bakeries.
AUDIENCE: And what's next?
JOANNE CHANG: Oh,
and what's next?
Writing the third book, and then
after that the "Myers and
Chang" book, definitely.
[LAUGHTER]
JOANNE CHANG: No.
This time I made Bill, my
publisher, commit to this.
I said, OK, so I'll do
this one, and then--
He actually had a good point.
He said that with the timing of
it, if I do the "Myers and
Chang" book, it will come out
at Myers and Chang's 10th
anniversary, which seems to make
sense and works and feels
good and all that.
And after that, I honestly
don't know.
Even though I'm talking about
how you have to have a clear
vision, I haven't had a
clear path about what
I want to do next.
I don't want to open more
bakeries, but I feel like I
have to be careful
when I say that.
Because I'm pretty sure when I
came here last time, when we
only had the three bakeries, I
probably said the same thing.
And yet, we opened a fourth.
But what's stopping us this time
from opening a fifth is
that physically we are limited
with how we're doing our
production.
If we were to open a fifth,
we would have to build a
commissary kitchen, which
we don't have now.
And so, for me, if we were to go
that route, that's a huge,
big next step.
That just changes the
business model.
Because right now, I can still,
in my head, convince
myself that I just have
four little bakeries.
But once you go commissary, then
you become commissary.
You're welcome.
AUDIENCE: Very interesting
connection with [INAUDIBLE]--
excuse me-- is how do you
define yourself--
I didn't come for the beginning,
so I might have
missed something you said--
compared to the other bakeries
in the area?
Iggy's obviously has a different
business model.
JOANNE CHANG: Sure.
AUDIENCE: But the product has
a lot of similarities.
Hi-Rise seems to be focused on
high price, which applies to
all of you.
How do you define yourself,
compared
to the other bakeries?
JOANNE CHANG: One thing that
we try to do is we try to
spend a lot of time just staying
focused on what we do
and not spend a lot of time
looking at what the others do
and how we relate
vis-a-vis them.
When I started Flour
13 years ago, it
was a couple of things.
It was, from a point of view,
making sure that that was
always a priority.
Which it sounds obvious,
you're opening a food
business, so of course food
should be obvious.
But it's very easy for a food
business, after a certain
number of years, to just kind
of go on automatic.
And so we spend a lot of time
really working on-- even
though the menu doesn't
change much--
constantly trying to tweak the
recipes and make them a little
bit better or figure out how
to do it a little bit
differently so that we're
interested but the customers
don't get upset that we've
changed something.
Then, again, part of my mission
statement 13 years ago
was trying to create an
environment that, as a
customer when you walk
in, you feel like--
it's cheesy, but I always say
it's like "Cheers"-- it's a
home away from home.
And that's what I want
Flour to be.
I want Flour to be a place
where people in the
neighborhood come to the bakery
and feel like it's
their place.
And in the South End,
for example--
that's the first one--
we have a ton of regulars
who we know on a
very personal level.
And they come in, and
it is their bakery.
They tell us what to change.
They clean up for us.
And it's become a really
nice community.
Obviously, people flit in and
flit out, but, for me, that's
something that--
I don't even know if it sets us
apart, because I don't know
what the other bakeries
are trying to do.
But I think all of the
bakeries around us--
I love Iggy's.
But to me, they're wholesale.
And I know they have the little
outpost I think on Fawcett--
AUDIENCE: Every Sunday.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, really?
OK.
AUDIENCE: That's where
I go every Sunday.
JOANNE CHANG: Oh, OK.
Yeah.
I think they're great.
But they're focusing on
wholesale, which is different.
AUDIENCE: That's why I said
about the business model.
Yeah.
JOANNE CHANG: I think the
closest to us, at this point--
Hi-Rise is very similar
to us, to what we do.
But he doesn't do the
fancy cakes, and so
we have that focus.
And then, Tatte Bakery I feel
like recently has become
similar to what we do.
Bread and Butter, which just
opened up in the North End, I
haven't been yet, but I think
it's similar to what we do.
I think there's enough people
out there to kind of be able
to have numerous bakeries and
just each place be a little
bit different, just based on
their own personalities.
Again, I'm not trying to define
myself vis-a-vis them.
I just try to define myself
vis-a-vis what
I'm trying to do.
And to the earlier question
about what would happen if I
were to move or stop being
involved every day, I feel
like that's what I'm always
doing is just trying to set
the tone of the place and the
spirit, so that when you walk
in it is clear that it's Flour
and not just one of the
various bakeries that
you can walk into.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: I think
we have time
for one more question.
AUDIENCE: So from the new
cookbook, what one recipe
would you say, oh, you've
got to try this one?
JOANNE CHANG: Uhh--
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: All of them.
JOANNE CHANG: Well, the book
is divided into breakfast,
lunch, dinner, party, drinks.
Give me a category, and
then I'll tell you.
AUDIENCE: Party.
JOANNE CHANG: OK.
Party time, I would say--
OK.
This isn't my answer, but I'm
just going to throw it out
there, because we
have samples.
The Spectacular Spice Pecans,
which don't look like much and
aren't like a sexy treat to
bring to an event like this,
the reason why we brought them
is that we did a book launch
party with this a couple weeks
ago and had this open house
with snacks from the book, and
the spiced pecans are the one
thing that everyone wrote about
and said to me, oh my
god, I love this.
But if you were to make
one thing from
that, I would say either--
I know I'm hedging here-- either
the Pithivier or the
Croquembouche, simply because
I think they're both really
dramatic and really beautiful.
They're both delicious.
And I think they're the type of
dessert that if you want a
project and you want to do
something that's going to
impress, I think those two
would do the trick.
They're both desserts that we
only offer at Christmastime,
and I spent a lot of time
working on the recipe to make
it accessible to people.
So they are a little bit long.
But if you follow the recipe
step by step, you'll get this
glorious dessert that you can
present of friends, and it's
pretty impressive.
You're welcome.
SANDRA LEUNG LI: Thank
you very much,
Joanne, for coming today.
JOANNE CHANG: Thank
you so much.
[APPLAUSE]